今回は天才小学生の僕がおもちゃを開く動
かだよいつも通りお母さんに邪魔されるん
だけど今回はどうなるのかぜひ見てみてね
[音楽]
はいバンキラジオオけああ忙しい忙しい
忙しいしぶしぶしぶ行け
けお母さんこれ買って
におもちゃなんて前に買ったのがたさ長
痛いんだけど俺におもちゃを買ってくれ
たらこんなメリットがあるよおもちゃで
遊ぶことによって俺のモチベーションが
上がってテストの成績もアップするかもお
金ないから無理よほほほほこのどけちおば
さんがこうなったら自分でおもちゃを作っ
て
やれでき
たせっかくだからみんなにも遊んで
もらおうイホ
みんなに今日は見せたいものがあるんだ何
ジじんスーパーアニマル
[音楽]
アンコ貧乏の僕にもお金う値があるって
わかるんよ売ってみ
たらおなんて学校に持ってきて
教えれ楽しいな楽しいな商品家か
お母さん新しいおもちゃ買ってよあんた
新しいおもちゃ買って結局使わないでしょ
おもちゃやトイおもちゃやトイス新商品
アニマル&コ何が入ってるか分からない
中身は全部で16種類ギーフレット図鑑を
見て動物について楽しく詳しく
学ぼう好評発売中あこれなら買ってあげて
もいいかも
お回
[拍手]
ですやっ
た俺の作ったおもちゃでみんでてせだな
と繁盛してるじゃないおい一体何しに来た
んだよ私たち親なんだから一緒に手に
決まってん
[音楽]
でしょ俺はお金稼ぎのためにやってるん
じゃないんだ
よもっと多くの人に俺のおもちゃで遊んで
ほしいなそうだ何でもおもちゃができる銃
ろなんだ助急に呼び出してこの前募集した
おもちゃはどうなったんですかあんなもの
とっくに勝負したに決まってるだろそう
ですかじゃあこれも興味ないですかねこれ
は激やろや先生はこんなものには何の興味
もないが生徒の頼みなら何でもくぞ本当
ですかありがとうございます
やこれは一体何の実験
だ撃ったものをおもちゃかするトイズガの
開発実験
ですやめて
[拍手]
くれ成功率は50%です
まだまだ改良が必要だ
なこのトイズガが完成したらもっと
たくさんのおもちゃを作れるように
[音楽]
なるこれさえあれば私もおもちゃを作って
おけよ助けてくれ助けてくれ
はいはい
はいおもちゃが大量だ
ちよし今日も頑張るぞいらっしゃいませ
いらっしゃい
ませなんで今日はお客さんが来ないんだ
おもちゃ屋
とこ転です
のおもちゃがなんと反逆
[拍手]
でなんで俺の商品
がお母さんもしかしてドイガ使ったのか何
だったら何よそれは開発と中で時間が経っ
たらあら手が滑っちゃったわ
け髪始り
[拍手]
[音楽]
ますおい
[拍手]
[音楽]
ラリラこれで邪魔者が消えたわみな買って
きなさいや
何の
[音楽]
音
あよかったやっと元の姿に戻れた
よとこです突然大量のもが待ち日本は大
パニックになっています
あこり大変なことになった
ぞ今すぐドイツガを完成させて動物たちを
おもちゃかしないと頼む
ぞ効率は100%ですよし
あああ
ああもうこれで大丈夫だ
[音楽]
後ろに
逃げろお母さんの暴走を止めなきゃきりが
ないでも俺1人じゃ
そう
だ撃たれたおもちゃが元に戻れ
ば
け
ピ先生お疲れ様でしたみ
[音楽]
は持ってきたなはいこれはくまさん小さい
頃ストレス解消に使ってたなボロボロすぎ
だろこれはダンボールいつもおったりして
遊んでるんよきたねうんち家に美したやつ
おもちゃって知っ
てる
[音楽]
け今まで僕たを使ってくれてありがとう
戦う覚悟はできてるみんな準備はいい
か行く
[音楽]
ぞ何よこの
ゴミかかったの
いやーいやいややややややや今だ
行け
何あんたも
またおもちゃになり
[音楽]
なさい
お子供の笑顔のために俺たちは負けるわけ
にはいかない
[音楽]
くらえ動物たちの暴走が止まり日本に平和
が訪れましたや
[音楽]
た何でもおもちゃにすればいいってもん
じゃないなこの銃ももういいいらないまた
新しいおもちゃ作るぞ
すきのせいで俺の人生めちゃくちゃ
だむにゃむにゃむにゃむにゃむにゃむにゃ
むにゃむにゃ
このおでパチンコ行って人生逆転する
[拍手]
ぜということで今回はスーパーラの案動画
でしたスーパはのに伸びる感触で自由な
発想で集める楽しいおもちゃだよ種類も
オフで開けるまで何が入ってるか分から
ない楽しさもあるわねこのカとかお母さん
によく似てそ今ならパッケージについてる
応募券を6枚集めるとプレゼント
キャンペーンに応募できるわよ詳しくは
概要欄を見てねちゃちゃちゃちゃ
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル
登録チャンネル登録よろしく最初は
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録